thank you thank you can you guys hear me
awesome
so our topic today is going to be
training and explaining long short term
memory models it's a very cool topic
this won't stay hold on so it's a topic
I'm pretty excited about I'm excited
about it for a number of reasons
primarily because these types of models
do you a very effective job of teasing
insights and finding patterns out of
unstructured data there's a lot of cool
products that are coming to market thank
you sorry it's gonna be a challenge for
me you have to remind me is that better
okay so there's a lot of cool products
that are coming to market that leverage
these methods so what we're going to
cover today really three big themes
number one why explain ability why is it
relevant why is it important we will
look at explain ability through the lens
of a user what goes in what goes out
what are some cool products that are
using these types of methods there's a
cohort of users that really value
explained ability so we'll touch on that
too
training menthe training long short-term
models here really the main goal is to
build intuition of what is going on
inside of these models with an eye on if
we're going to explain it what are some
of the key pieces of these models we
need to have an intuition about three
we'll shift gears in to explain ability
the bulk of that is going to be around a
very very cool
is that better the bulk of the third
part is going to be around a very cool
tool called lsdm vis which is out of
Harvard's NL up and LLP lab and it's so
I'm not going to move so lsdm vis is a
very cool tool these are very
complicated models and it does I think a
very neat job visualizing what's going
on before we go on just a quick show of
hands who here is familiar with or has
trained a recurrent neural network same
questions but for long short-term memory
models familiar with our trained
ok so roughly 1/3
so for you third you may be but a little
bit bored for parts of this the other
2/3 you might feel I'm going a little
too quickly there's a lot to this
there's a lot of detail details I'm just
going to brush over what I'm trying to
focus on is the intuition and I think
that's the important part to get to the
explain ability a little bit about
myself think of me as one part
management consultant one part data
scientist one part technologist a guest
lecturer at Columbia on topics similar
to these
okay maybe if we turn this microphone
off so if you want to reach out to me
bill see gold across all of these
platforms and sometime tomorrow I'll
post this presentation and some of the
code up onto github sorry folks on that
side of the room so it's a big week for
me for a couple of reasons
number one I'm very excited about the
speech this presentation number two I'm
going back to my masters
that started Monday at Georgia Tech so
this is MIMO on his first day of school
and number three for the first time ever
I'm presenting to an audience where my
son is here I'm very excited about that
another back to school reference anyone
know what this movie is back to school
excellent
do you know the name of the dive
close yeah the triple-n destroyed okay-y
explained ability this room okay there's
a lot of relevance to explain ability I
think but first why should we use LST ms
they are very very effective at
predicting the next item in the sequence
and I'd ask you to think about sequences
very broadly they can be continuous data
and stock prices you can think of it as
pixels in a picture there's a sequence
of pixels what's the next pixel that's
going to appear you could think of it as
audio signals you can think of language
it's very much a sequential piece of
data and that's going to be a big part
of what we're going to be focusing on
here what are LST M models used for the
you see them day-to-day as part of auto
responses and email and text messaging
many people are using LST M models for
documents or creating new documents for
summarizing existing documents and you
might also see those in customer service
automation with various chat BOTS so
they're becoming more and more prevalent
so here in this demo the input is
cursive handwriting the model is
outputting the characters that are
written up on top and this is all based
on in lsdm model this is I think a good
example of pixel data right we can't
turn that down on the amplifier so I'm
trying to turn it down the mic is this
so the audience can hear me or it can be
recorded the audience can you guys hear
me without the microphone how are the
people in the back is there anyone who
can hear me yeah that's stitch that okay
using Gmail right there's all sorts of
very very cool auto suggestions that
Gmail will present to you and shade the
shaded gray they call that smart compose
well they don't use L STM's they use a
variety of models that are cousins of
Alice tiems
to do that so inside of that what Google
has done is they've experimented with
many many different types of methods and
the two that bubbled up to the top
number one seek to seek a number two a
combination of neural bag-of-words
and recurrent language models while the
seek to seek had slightly better
performance and slightly better accuracy
there's a significantly more expensive
cost to executing that so ultimately
this team chose to go with the latter
remember we're still in the looking at
this from the user mode another area
that's gaining lots of traction with
with long short-term memory models is in
document processing in this particular
area it's in the legal domain so imagine
that someone is in a store and they slip
and fall or they chip a tooth
on some food the legal process is to
file a complaint and then the store will
respond with a request for production
which is really a request for
information they're generating these
requests for productions now based on
long short term memory models it's it's
pretty fascinating I think with all the
cool stuff what's going on inside it
really has this massive black box
quality to it so for many that's okay
and for often with lots of these deep
learning models they're making
suggestions that a human is choosing to
accept or to override your auto prompts
on text messages sometimes they're right
sometimes they're not self-driving car
features they're making suggestions and
decisions but you as the driver can
override those many times but these are
really complicated models so I'm going
to shift gears a little bit but just to
articulate the point that there's
millions of activations that are going
on inside of these networks so stepping
a little bit away from long short-term
memory models this is an example of
ResNet and with ResNet this has millions
and millions of activations inside so
these are all different layers and some
of these models have up to a hundred and
fifty two layers and any one of these
boxes might be a 256 by 256 convolution
so if you imagine the linear algebra
that's going on here and the calculus of
going backwards and forwards and
propagations it's absolutely massive so
while the results are really astounding
and as of four years ago the error rate
was 3% now that's below 1% there is this
big I want to emphasize that there's
this big black box quality to these so
why explain ability and
what do we need we need to focus a
little bit on the architecture the the
massive quantity of activations and the
fact that many of these are using
unstructured data makes us a more
complicated factor so one or shift gears
a little bit and and shift to a
real-world example for a real old model
I've trained so Sippi who knows what
sippy stands for in the banking context
systemically important financial
institution these big banks have to
stress test their portfolios and those
results have to be defended internally
to model governance teams and they have
to be defended externally to the federal
government and the the office of the
controller of the currency and the
Treasury Department so one model
I trained contained five variables for
that one model I generated five hundred
pages of documentation it was just
everything it was it was the full
lineage of the data it was the quality
checks and profiling of the data it was
the the universe of variables considered
why they were chosen why they were
rejected the various methods we used the
regularization it was a massive
undertaking it was my best guess 25,000
team hours over the course of nine
months and this was just one of 15
products that the bank brought to market
so in this credit risk role not only do
they value explained ability but they're
compelled by federal laws to have
explained ability so really what kind of
excites me about this topic is there are
many stakeholders that can benefit from
these methods but choose not to use them
and choose not to use them for really
compelling reasons that they have to
explain where they feel the explain
ability is an important part of their
their business model so some of these
cohorts are credit risk in the
texts stress testing whether it's C car
Basel Fair Credit Reporting legal
community lawyers are traditionally the
laggards and accepting and ramping up on
new technologies they're thinking about
is it accurate their whole case can
hinge on one word selection they are
very much focused on what biases exist
it's it's unusual for me to think of
legal as a data rich field but would
these tools it really is but in order
for there to be broad acceptance of
these methods within a legal community
explain ability has to be a big part of
the solution in medical diagnostics so
if there's convolutional neural networks
that can detect tumors more accurately
than doctors but to use things like that
requires all sorts of FDA approval okay
so that's the chapter on why explain
ability is compelling let's shift gears
and start talking about training however
before we do that I often spend a little
more time on trying to put out funny
titles than I should be so would anyone
here care to guess what my inspiration
for training and explaining would be you
can't guessed in any basketball fans
Knicks fans maybe not
pardon Clyde Frazier you got it exactly
so he's the face of announcing the New
York Knicks he's a point guard all-star
very and he he talks and Rimes posting
and toasting dishing and swishing
probably had the game on while I was
thinking about this and came up with
training and explaining alright so in
this training section our goals are
really to gain an intuitive
understanding of what's going on inside
of long short-term memory models to do
that we're going to talk about the
architectures will touch briefly on the
mathematics of this and then we'll go
through some our code that leverages
Kerris and tensor flow to train a pair a
fairly simplistic model and what we'll
also do is we'll take a bit of a step
back and first delve into recurrent
neural networks which are long term long
short-term memory models are an
extension of so what is a recurrent
neural network it is a model that's very
effective at sequencing it is
essentially taking an input it is taking
deep learning networks have all sorts of
hidden states inside of them but what it
does that's fairly unique is it pulls at
in state from the previous point in time
so it has this quality of shifting time
there's a terrific blog post by Andre Co
Parthi on the unreasonable effectiveness
of RN ends the link is in here I'd
encourage you all to look at it if this
is a topic of interest we're going to
touch it on some of the key gaps of them
and then we'll go through a few examples
so in an RNN think of three different
layers input layer output layer and this
hidden layer in between what I'd like
you to take away from this that one also
do this the input layer is feeding up
into the hidden layer in the same time
sequence so the time goes this way along
the x-axis
but then the hidden layer shift in time
with these to go to the next output
layer and that's where you get some of
the sequencing qualities of this and
there's a time shift involved which was
what makes this architecture
particularly well-suited for sequencing
for Rick and Morty fans they're often
referencing time travel does anyone know
what movie Rick and Morty's based on
back to the future exactly okay there's
lots of different architectures involved
with RNN I just want to give you a
flavor of that there's one two one two
ones there's many too many's and there's
all sorts of architectures in between
and to build on the intuition of this
let's imagine that the sequence that we
want to predict for is really a sequence
of characters okay so we're going to
start built building out the word hello
each character gets encoded as a numeric
the unique numeric and then on the
output layer we're getting the
probability that the next character of
what the next character was going to be
take the the highest probability and
call that our output in between we have
our hidden layers and and and the
training process is going to [ __ ]
these around do a bunch of calculus but
ultimately figure out the best hidden
layer that will encode your inputs to
the outputs ultimately this all distills
down to y equals x w plus b where W and
B are your weights and biased and this
middle layer right here
this is the blog post where a lot of
this is referenced it encourage you all
to take a look at that all right there
are two key gaps I want to talk about
with the recurrent neural network one is
the exploding gradient the other is the
vanishing gradient Arden's have a big
biased towards recency they're
constantly looking at one hidden layer
in one time step backwards as a result
that close and recent information
carries a big heavy bias on the
exploding side as you're doing all this
calculation of forward and backward
propagation little numbers can explode
and become big fortunately this is
easily fixed and this is fixed by
clipping the gradient basically taking a
shaving a percentage off the harder one
to solve is the vanishing gradient and
here I'd like to give you a little
intuition of what that means so imagine
this sentence I grew up near Queens
great childhood memories sports friends
family dog my favorite baseball team is
oh good gasps that is awesome the answer
is the Mets but what are the two key
pieces of information to get to that
sequence baseball and and Queens
baseball and Queens right so if it's an
RNN the iron then will do a very good
job with baseball it's close where the
RNN is going to struggle is with the
Queens it's pretty distant pretty far
back that's a great guy wish I had
prizes good guess
so this is an architecture mathematical
view of the vanishing gradient you can
see the time sequence along the x-axis
and you can see within our hidden layers
as it the shading gets lighter and
lighter it really over many steps it
just vanishes and really the key thing
to take away from this is that the
sensitivity to that decay is exponential
and it's exponential because of all the
calculus baked inside of these models
okay
so let's shift gears out of RN ends and
start focusing on long short-term memory
models the genesis of this is in 1997 I
believe with this paper so the kind of
cool thing about a lot of these methods
is they're not particularly new they've
been around for a long time
convolutional neural networks are from I
think the 60s so the key thing to take
out of this and we'll do well will
unpack what this is doing but they're
much more effective with the long term
interactions how do they do that so the
diagram for the law LS TM looks at a
high level very similar to the RNA it's
got our sequence going along here we've
got hidden States we've got the previous
state feeding into the next state where
things start to get really really
interesting is what's going on in each
one of those cells ok and there's a lot
to unpack here but conceptually the way
to think about each and every one of
those cells is it's a network into
itself
guys remember this movie Inception right
so it's it has a quality of being a
network within a network and the
inception is about dreams within dreams
so unpacking the ostium there's a few
concepts I'd like to articulate one is
the cell state and that's what we're
learning and learning to remember one of
those gates inside of the individual
note is called a forget gate and the job
of that gate is is to say what
information should we keep away from the
cell state and and more quickly and
trying to define it without using the
word forget but but is not important and
should be set aside
there's inputs and there's outputs and
and the key thing here is each and every
one of these has its own set of weights
has its own gating criteria so that as
the model trains each one of these can
can train to the task it has its
responsible for okay one by one so the
cell state what even what I'd like you
to think about is this vertical line
here it's running through the top it's
the cell state so this is C t minus 1 is
the previous cell state C of T is the
next cell state think of it like a
conveyor belt information is passing
through it and as the information passes
through this
we're tinkering with it and we're
tinkering with it based on what the
forget gate is is is thinking the answer
should be and and what the input and the
predicted cell state should be so
they're all influencing this conveyor
belt some of the interactions are minor
sometimes there's no changes at all but
there's a constant flow of information
going through here what are the gates to
the gates here ultimately they're adding
information into this conveyor belt
they are often driven by sigmoids so one
are zero the one is telling us to
completely retain the information that's
flowing through the zero is to say
completely set aside whatever the
information is flowing through it's not
very good Bill Gates memes out there so
I apologize on this one it's about the
loan
taking the bank taking out a loan from
Bill Gates yes of it all right let's
talk about the forget gates the forget
gate is inputting taking our input the X
sub T it's taking the previous hidden
state and it's combining those through a
sigmoid and you can its ultimate it's
decision is what information do we throw
away and the mathematics of it are dot
products between the weights which we're
going to determine through training the
previous hidden state and the input plus
whatever bias
and I apologize that I'm going through
this quickly but really what I'd like
you to take away from this is the
intuition inputs and candidate cell
states similar idea with the inputs it's
going through a sigmoid it's inputs are
the previous hidden state and its own
set of weights the candidate cell state
is kind of interesting whereas the
sigmoid goes from zero to one fully keep
fully throw away what's the job of the
10h
between negative one and one so it's
taking our our 0 to 1 distribution and
forcing that to a minus 1 to a 1 so our
negative values have a meaning to the
model other than throwing away so with
the candidate again it has its own set
of weights it takes the previous hidden
state its inputs and it's going to
spread that out over minus 1 to 1 so
just to give a linguistic intuition of
what might be going on here and this is
just a made-up example but perhaps
gender is part of the sentence and then
there's a new subject that might appear
that the cell state is trying to find
signals for and perhaps it's trying to
replace the new subject with the old one
that we're forgetting and I'm just
making this up but I'm trying to connect
it back to the linguistics of what might
be going on here
I was a little nervous about putting
this one up there maybe dating myself
okay the cell state so the cell state's
purpose is to really be a geat and to do
all sorts of linear algebra it's going
to do our multiplication of the forget
gate and it's going to take the inputs
and and dot product that with the
candidate for the cell state okay you
can see those all make its way back into
the conveyor belt of the cell state and
lastly for each state we're going to
have an output you know in the earlier
example in the word hello we were
predicting the next character so somehow
that needs to be output and that's the
function of the output gate it too has a
sigmoid it too has its own sets of
weights and biases and that gets pushed
through at NH and makes its way back up
into the cell states so again a made up
example of linguistic intuition for the
cell States maybe it just saw subject
and now with the subject
maybe there's a verb it wants to attach
up to that and that verb might talk to
some of the conjugations about so
whether it's singular or plural of
things of that nature
the last I knew I never have a crepe
cake from lady am best dessert ever in
my opinion anyway I want to talk about
layers because with all the complexity
that's going through the complete
conveyor belt here the other layer packs
complexity is these have a deep quality
and these states can get stacked up on
top of each other so there's a lot of
moving parts there's a lot of gates
there's a lot of hidden states which
translates into a ton of linear algebra
and in the case of natural language
processing there's graphs there there's
graphs that define the universe of words
that we want to be passing through and
getting out of this model this is just
another visualization of layers the
purpose of this is to give you a little
bit of context about some of the hyper
parameters that go into defining these
architectures there's a size of what you
want to recur there's the number of
layers there's different types of models
the way the the GPUs and the training
happens they break up the mathematics
into chunks so they're not processing
everything at once that's our batch size
there's a lot of pieces that go into
defining this and I'm not going to touch
on all of them but what I'd like you to
take away from this is it's a fairly
complicated endeavor
okay so let's shift gears here a little
bit and let's look at a real world
example and I was inspired by this from
things that I found online but the task
here is to take questions from croire
and to classify them we're going to
classify them as sincere with a zero or
not sincere with the one okay and we're
going to pass all of these into our LS
TM so first step is we're going to set
up our libraries and define some
parameters we're going to work with
Kerris as you guys worked with Karis
okay yeah you know so basically it's a
it's a cleaner way to get to temperature
flow
we'll use the tiny verse and data table
we're gonna set some parameters that
feet up into the model you guys should
be familiar with most of that next we're
going to create tokens we're going to
pull on some training data and some
testing data we're going to create
tokens which is really the converting
the text to sequence of integers and
ultimately we're going to pad those with
LST M's it likes to have its text of
equal length throughout so we'll 0 pad
those and I briefly toyed with the idea
of doing this in real time with you guys
but on a pretty beefy desktop it took a
few hours to train so you'll forgive me
if we're sticking to PowerPoint here
splitting the data this should look
fairly familiar there's labels there's
training tests and validation and you
can see the splits down here
embeddings so a big part of natural
language processing is a corpus and
that's our universe of words we know
there's a number of those that are
publicly available some are from
Wikipedia dues some are from Google
there's lots and lots of good options
often what happens when people are doing
these in an industry focused way they
will use industry specific corpuses
there are corpuses for law for medical
etc but there's we pull in our wiki
corpus here we loop through the
embeddings and ultimately we're going to
land these in matrixes and arrays and
the thing to take away from this is they
use dense vectors in this particular
example if you think of corpuses of
words both on an x and y axis
what's going to happen if you have a
million words sparse it's going to
become very very very sparse so one way
to work around that is to use these
dense matrixes I'm part of meat
inspectors a dense vector vector yeah
vector yeah I could show you an example
at the end but basically it's one word
with a bunch of continuous variables
after it that say what other words that
word of interest is associated with okay
so let's define what we want the
architecture of our elet I'm sorry oh it
was um Wikipedia news about a million
rows I think they're available online it
wouldn't I post this there'll be links
to all this you can get it off of my
github did that answer your question
so let's define our model architecture
we're gonna have a Karass model and
we're gonna define various layers within
that so we drop in our word embeddings
we are going to I think I skipped a page
part of me I'm sorry go back yeah so
let's talk about some of the layers that
are inside of this model here we have
our our wiki word embedding a corpus
here we're defining that this is going
to be an LST m and some of the
parameters that define the ostium drop
outs which is basically saying amongst
all the activations inside of the
network only drop only you 75% of those
drop out 25% and the benefit of that is
without that feature most of these
models tend to over fit here we're
defining what we want are our dense
layer to have is reloj units and we're
also going to have sigmoid for our
gating and activations
now we're pulling it all together to
build the model inputs and predictions
embeddings and then we're going to
compile it we're going to use Adam for
stochastic gradient descent and
essentially what that is doing is we
start out the model randomize our
weights we we have what we want the
training label to be we pass through all
the different gates and and do a lot of
linear algebra and we come out with an
answer and we measure the error the
accuracy what would between what we it
should be and what the model measured it
to be so now what we have to decide to
do is we need to change the weights to
get to a more accurate answer but how do
we know what direction to change the
weights into the way we do that is we do
calculus back through the model it's
just called stochastic gradient descent
is one way to do it
Adam is another way to do it but
ultimately when we do all that calculus
the answer that's going to pop out is
change the direction to change your
weights are the way it's going to get
smaller they're going to get bigger and
then we go through and loop through the
model again and the goal is to do this
many many times and to shrink the error
we're in the model debrief in here some
in these embedding layers there's a
default the LS TM layer I'd to believe
by default has one or two layers inside
of Karass there's a default to that
parameter as you pick out that it sells
TM you can explicitly define the
quantity of layers and it's just picking
out the default it's good question
yes exactly exactly so by default it's a
good point there's three layers input
output and hidden and the the the hyper
parameter lets us define how many hidden
layers we want I have to go back and
look I forget if the default is one or
two so we've set up the model
architecture and there's a couple of
things I'd like to highlight here number
one the total quantity of parameters
inside of here
is 4.6 million the the number that Karis
found to be trainable is a hundred and
one thousand these are just massive
quantities of activations so we as data
scientists it's a big challenge I think
to get our heads wrapped around what
these models are doing so how do you
explain that to a user how do you
explain that to a lawyer so I think
there's a ton of value to do it but but
to do it is not a trivial undertaking
and I believe that the advancement these
methods have made is getting further
away from the explained ability and
there's value in this explained ability
I believe
yes yes
I would imagine that if you choose to
order haven't explicitly tried to do
that but I would surmise if you ordered
your data by that dependent variable
you're gonna pull the model around in
really big directions so if you're
feeling if you're feeding in only since
ears the wheats are gonna get themselves
comfortable with since here and then
when you hit the next one that's
unsecured you're gonna come up with a
big error and you're gonna have some big
walking of your variables to get back to
your conceptually regressing to the mean
right I haven't done it it into of a
intuitively doesn't feel right and
ultimately what's going to drive these
things the way people tend to do these
things quicker is tuning your hyper
parameters and leveraging things like
GPUs that's where people typically see
the benefit in training this it's a good
question I would speculate it would add
to the training time
and here we fit the model it's going to
come through 30 epochs 30 an epoch is
just a training cycle of going backwards
and forwards in our propagation and at
the end of the day we're getting
accuracy of 95% let's say over here it's
pretty good and here's a GG plot that
tells us what's going on as we train the
model so on the top our y-axis is Los
our x-axis is the epic epic a training
iteration of full training iteration and
it's a nice plot you can see over time
as we do more and more training the loss
rates are coming down and the accuracy
is going up there's a little bit of a
virgin's here and it'd be interesting to
look under the hood which driving that
but 95% is a pretty good accuracy I
would want me to check to make sure that
we're not overfitting it kind of sends
up a flag that we might be doing that
but the purpose of this exercise is to
take you through the life cycle of
training all right let's try this I
spent way too much time trying to get
this gif in here but
I personally think this is a great
metaphor I think it's great because
conceptually the way we come at these
deep learning models are we say here's
the answer here's a bunch of data and
here's a bunch of calculus and linear
algebra and and graphs of text in these
examples in between like a child learn
learn where the signals are then you
know over at first it's not going to
look pretty you can have ugly losses but
over time it should get better
you can have all sorts of output layers
and gates that I'll turn that into a
classifier so there's a probability so
if you go one layer back you're gonna
have a probability and you can cut that
off you can have output classifiers
attached to the LCM you can define what
that output layer is and it elude the
term eludes me at the moment they'll
think of it but you can define what you
want that all sorts of classifier type
algorithms in that output layer that's
ultimately going to give you one a 1 and
a 0 and behind it there there's it's
like a probit model we might have a zero
to whine in some cutoff above that it's
a one below that it's a zero that's the
concept I'll think of the term in a
minute I'll come back to you
explaining do you guys know what this is
from Breaking Bad very good alright so
the remainder of this presentation is
going to be focusing on LS TM bits it's
this analysis system it's very visual
and it has all sorts of very cool
graphical renderings of what's going on
inside these LS TM networks and what to
do with all these states you remember
the cell state that was going through
there
what is going on with those cell states
so this tool came out I think in 2016
there's a white paper there's a white
paper associated with it the there's a
lot of information that we're going to
unpack here and if I could get online
will actually go through and use and
touch the tool but the way I think about
it is you have people that architect the
networks you have people that are going
to train it and ultimately you have
users this in my mind is predominantly a
tool for the architects and for the data
scientists that train their networks to
tease out what patterns are significant
what activations are significant inside
the network and ultimately communicate
that because in my mind a goal of a
model is not necessarily the most
accurate one it's the ones that the
people who use it embrace one that they
choose to use it that they feel
ownership and the stake in it and that
the knowledge of their business that
they bring to the table they have a good
sense of how this model is going to
behave in those various scenarios
all right let's unpack what's going on
here
so first let's think of an overly
simplistic language okay the only
purpose of this language is to count the
number of open parentheses so what we're
doing here is every time there's a left
parenthesis we're incrementing a counter
by one and every time there's a right
parenthesis we're going to decrement the
counter by one so I'm not a big fan of
these overly simplistic examples but
there's a lot going on so just bear with
me for a minute here
so what we're doing what we're gonna do
is we're gonna take this language we're
going to pass it through analysis else
TM viz and we want the model to predict
the next sequence in this language is it
a parenthesis
open parentheses close parentheses or a
number so there are two main parts this
tool on the top is all about selections
and on the bottom is about matching the
data that we've selected all right let's
go through it one by one
pardon me all right let's go this way so
I'm gonna go back and forth but there's
a couple I could do it on the screen
there's a couple of things I want to
point out here
what is this graph up top our x-axis is
the sequence of input words that we've
fed into lsdm bits so it's it's our
parentheses language the y-axis all
these lines are the hidden states those
blocks that make up the sequence if it's
an RNN or the blocks that contain our
various forget input output it's the
activation associated with that and it's
telling us that what is activating
inside of the network so one observation
you can take from this is you see when
the parentheses hit the activation spike
up so that's telling us that these
transitions between parentheses are
causing the hidden states inside of the
network's
activate more and the way we got here is
we selected this blue bar is this moving
up them yeah okay so this was we brushed
over this causing this two parentheses
to be highlighted and what that did was
it said well there's one path through
the hidden state where at this sequence
the activations exceeded our threshold
and that's what this red line is here so
we can connect the sequence to
activations and what's firing and what
hidden states are relevant and what we
also get is this matching component down
here so we selected two parentheses and
here the tool is showing us inside of
our inputs whether other ranges are
similar to what we selected and I'll
show you in the tool but the cool thing
here is it can create all sorts of heat
maps that are interactive and say
amongst these similar parts of the
impact of the inputs what other match
counts are relevant
let me pause here because this is an
important part before we go into some of
the others is you guys have any
questions about this pardon
oh you bet you bet so on the bottom the
question is on the lower right this this
heat map what is this
step number one we selected the input
that was of interest
step number tool the tool came back to
us and said here are parts of your input
that are similar to what you selected so
we selected two parentheses and you can
see down here here's two - two - two
parentheses you parentheses these are
other inputs in the sequence that are
similar to what we selected and then
it'll become clear on the input but then
as you mouse over this in the heat map
it's going to connect these high match
counts back to the other sequences so
it's it's a way of scanning what is
matching here to the alternate sequence
that the tool came back to us it'll be a
little clearer when I show you
interactively I'm gonna step out of the
parentheses language for a minute
because I want to highlight another
feature and then we'll go into some
real-world examples so the input here is
from a children's book we can see that
input here along the blue line on the
bottom and these are four different
examples of the same sequence and
they're all telling us something
slightly different and I'll walk us
through that so what we brushed over was
a little prince okay and now a little
prince said these are all the
activations inside of your network that
are relevant the ones that are
highlighted in blue but there's
something curious about this what is
curious about this is that some of the
activations are completely above the
line
and some of them are below the line and
at times what's really important to us
is the transitions what was not what was
previously not important but now due to
this word change what became important
so if we look over here what we've done
is we've extended this brushstroke over
here to the left a little bit and in
doing so these lines up on the top
shifted from blue to gray and now we can
focus on just those elements that
activated in this transition over here
so it's a way of connecting the inputs
to the various activations and the
patterns and the activations and
similarly we extended the this line over
here on the right and we're we're
filtering down to those hidden states
that are making the difference for this
network the network Transpo pardon me in
a little prince how are we doing for
time okay so let me do this let me shift
gears and go to the actual tool
I think that'll might be a little more
compelling
[Music]
so we're gonna go to the live server and
there's the parentheses model so there's
roughly a dozen or so models that are
liven up and running these are all
trained and they're all plugged directly
into Elsa TM DES so I'm gonna pick one
of these and PC a that was the answer
so with this all right here's a real
world example so first thing we're gonna
do is just take a look at our sequence
of words from the children's book that
we're fed into this model and I'm gonna
randomly pick some of these let's say
been glad enough okay and immediately
that took our universe of probably
thousands of different hidden states and
distilled it down to four and we can see
those enumerated over here and then so
this is this is sort of the selection of
what we want to focus on and now what
we're gonna do is let's take a look to
see what matches here so been glad
enough what's the model consider to be
similar to that all right
been glad enough you may be okay was
writing through and what we can do here
is we can come at this either through
the LexA graph of the text that was fed
in or we can go through it from the heat
map to say where are there many counts
that are activating this network in
different areas and we get that linkage
between the heat map on the right
and the language elements on the left
and there's other metrics that we can
drop into this this particular model
includes parts of speech which I'm going
to parts of speech except so now what
we're gonna do is included in our graph
the various parts of speech that we're
trained as part of this model nouns
pronouns verbs I don't know about you
guys but I went into data science
because I felt I wouldn't have to deal
with this stuff so but we can come at it
from a couple of ways we can scan the
heat map for verbs and punctuation and
we can connect that to other parts of
the linguistics where the tool is
telling us there's similar linguistics
what would the folks who built this did
that I think is pretty cool prior to
this a lot of the analysis of these
hidden states was in the form of heat
maps and heat maps are good and they
have their place but where they fall
apart is they lose the time-series
quality that's inherent in these models
and it starts to fall apart when these
get massive so so the approach they took
was to include the time series in the
form of the linguistics on the x axis
the hidden states that are relative bent
on the y axis and the heat maps down
here the other thing you can do in this
model is you can zoom let's see where is
it sorry
position pardon me so we can shift
around in our inputs a couple of ways we
can move to a numerical location or we
can search for various terms not sure
what else is in here a kids book play
let's see if that comes up there we go
and then we can jump to these various
parts of the Linguistics yes
so the question is how's the taxonomy
that we see on the bottom apply to other
domains the way I'd like you to think
about the bottom is that's our input
that's our X so that's what's being fed
into the model under the covers there's
a taxonomy and and it comes in two ways
number one you're going to take from
your inputs unique set of words the
model is going to be trained to in each
one of those unique words we'll get a
number placed up against that why these
models work with linear algebra right
there is a taxonomy behind that that's
not really bubbling out you could go
into we could go into the code this
codes up on github and we could see that
but the way to think about the bottom is
is our X and our series of inputs did
that enter your question
yeah yeah um no no no it's less about
the training process and this Alice TM
think of LS TM vis as picking up after
trainings complete it's not describing
for us the journey of training we're at
the destination the models been trained
what is going on within all these
millions of activations and hidden
states and ultimately I think what this
is doing in my humble opinion of doing a
really good job of stepping down the
path of of shining a light on to what
these hidden states are doing making the
connections across various parts of the
input stream of words that are similar
and do similar words produce similar
outputs or are they producing something
vastly different I'm sorry
yeah there's a there's a a distance
metric inside of Altium vis that's
saying these phrases are similar so it's
at each state it's good to predict what
the next word is in the path so ideally
what this model would do or it says
child could you'd want the model to say
play so we these are whether it's words
or stock prices or pixels these models
are gonna predict the next step and I
didn't cover that so thank you
correct that's right that's exactly
right so the question is what's the
y-axis it's the value of the activations
what what is activating and what's not
good question so the question is is this
the PCA at the output layer is it
something in between and the way that
gets decided is you can pick so you can
pick the tool gives you the ability to
interrogate the layer of your choice
exactly exactly if I could paraphrase
what you say is said is that you might
think of this architecture differently
between continuous data and language
data and and this particular tool is
shining a light on the language part and
a lot of the parts of the model that are
necessary to to deal with the language
elegantly did I understand that
correctly
yeah
that's right
thank you
that's right that's right and it's a
good point because there's so many
different architectures and you look at
all these papers and they all come up
with their own flavor of the
architecture
so there's by no means a
one-size-fits-all but the the issue I
think goes across all of these different
types of architectures different flavors
of what you're predicting for the
question I think is where does this type
of visualization and the explain ability
really drive a lot of value and at least
from what I've seen the places where it
drives a ton of value is often connected
to linguistics and one of the ideas I
had to do with this as I was going
through and preparing this and one of my
pet peeves is those parentheses examples
that are kind of rudimentary and really
don't carry real-world significance so
one of my aspirations in preparing this
and it always takes more time than I
thought
was to take a bunch of 10 K statements
from from businesses and take a series
of 10 KS from the same company and train
a series of ls TMS same company
different kottar nuu else TM and then
somehow use this to get a sense of how
the 10 K vary over time R is Apple
changing a phrase or in a particular
quarter and is there a signal there
that's of meaning that was one idea I
don't know maybe at the next talk
good question so two broad ways you can
think about these models is each input
is a word that gets encoded so play is
zero zero zero one child is zero zero
zero two another way you can choose to
architect these models is on a character
basis so each is 0 0 0 1 is 0 0 1 0 etc
etc that's just an architecture decision
of how do you want to set up your model
in this particular example the model the
model is architected around words so
each word will get encoded into a unique
number so it's one of the architecture
decisions that you're going to go
through as you set up these models yes
yes yes yes and then you have that
encoding on the inputs and the outputs
to get you out of the text world and
into the linear algebra world
now I know I'm standing between you and
the bar
yeah so typically what so the question
is before you do the training do you
adjust for spelling and things like that
it depends on your case you know if you
if you're training in the real world
about how people I don't know
tweet or respond on Quora or you might
say people will actually the real world
has spelling errors so you may choose to
include that you may choose not to
that's a design decision but more
importantly what you're going to do is
you're going to standardize your data
and and you might say run runs running
all come down to the same stem word and
and there's a standardizing step in
encoding that
so is the question what's kind of be
more resource intensive your database
server or the training of this they're
different sure sure sure sure sure
so I'll qualify it I won't clarify it
but your your database servers tend to
be i/o bound and
[Music]
totally totally yep yep I'll tell you
you mean bottleneck and performance for
these is CPU these are really really
really CPU intensive if you heard my
server it's just a big beefy desktop it
was chugging away in the CPU for hours
training that that little test sample
and the way people address that is they
use GPUs and the GPUs they're awesome
you can get an nvidia card for a few
hundred dollars that has three six
thousand cores on it and the good thing
about all this linear algebra it breaks
down into operations that can be
parallelized
very elegantly so what you'll do to
speed up these processes is you use
tensorflow with the GPU libraries and
that will enable you to put that onto a
GPU and do all of your training on the
GPU then you want to size the amount of
memory you have on the GPU they can have
two four six eight gigs ideally you want
to get a good chunk of your data to sit
on that GPU so you don't have to swap
out in and out of the GPU frequently and
that's where you get into tuning your
batch sizes so one of the hyper
parameter is a batch size how much do
you feed onto the GPU at a time that's
really where you get your bang for the
buck and by the way getting all this to
work with the GPU I mean I've lost
weekends that I will never ever ever get
back trying to get all that to work it's
not fun it's extraordinary sensitive to
what version of which package in which
library you're using and and I have a
big beefy server everything's good there
I tried to set it up on my desktop too
I got it to work I had the things going
in and out of the Nvidia card and I
rebooted
it may scream when totally black it just
walked all over the graphics drivers and
I'm deciding if I'm gonna fix that
myself or pay someone to fix it
any other questions I think that's most
of what I have
there's a lot of varieties there's gr
use is bi-directional Isles TMS that's a
good so there's one other one I'm aware
of there's a seek to seek visualizer
there's a paper about it I've glanced at
the paper I haven't touched the tool I
can't speak to the quality of it I know
it exists but I'll tell you what I do
want to do I think this is a super
powerful and exciting tool for the data
scientist but my goal is to have the
folks that use the models embrace them
and one of the domains I operate in is
in the law the legal world that's a huge
challenge it is you know what the
lawyers will tell you is an entire case
can hinge on one word and they're
looking for smoking guns and it's their
reputation and that sensitivity to
accuracy and word choice is a big deal
to them so one of the things that I
would like to see out of this and I've
been tinkering with is I'd like to scan
all the inputs and I'd like to take the
phrases that are most common and I'd
like to wrap that up into a simple and
elegant user interface and be able to
pass just those phrases through and show
the user what outputs those phrases
create and I'd like to have the user
have the ability to enter in the phrases
that they think are important and see
what the model outputs from the phrases
the user thinks is important and I think
that interactive testing in a really
user friendly mode would go a long way
to stress testing the model to gaming
either finding weaknesses in the model
or gaining confidence from the user
community in the model
so I think this is an important step for
the data scientist to narrow down areas
that should be interrogated but
ultimately I think the ownership of that
interrogation should be with the users
and I think it's our job to enable that
yeah I grew that I think that's really
smart and have you been following what
Stanford has done recently they just
rebranded their whole comps I a I group
as human artificial intelligence I think
is really smart and I think they're
going for a lot of what you're talking
about is the compliment of what humans
can do and and and what machines the the
breadth and speed of what machines can
do in ways that generalize well and
knowing that not all things generalize
well yeah yeah yeah yeah there was a
great use case about that one of the
things they did on this journey is I
kind of audited it a handful of Stanford
classes it's a it's a cool thing to do
because a the professors are rock stars
be they'll take a really interesting
topic and they'll mix it up between the
math the intuition and they'll
intersperse here's what the latest
research papers tell you it's just a
very compelling way to go through a
class but on draco parthy who wrote that
great blog post for a while taught a
class on convolutional neural networks
since then he went to work at Tesla and
is on top of their autonomous driving
group there's a great YouTube where
Tesla opens up their their automated
driving group for a day and they
showcase it to the media in the way they
talk about it I thought was interesting
number one they it's not they frame it
is not a big data problem because
there's so many outlier cases of getting
a car to drive itself
what are you do in a parking lot what do
you do when it's snowing what do you do
when you can't see the lines so what
they've done which is crazy clever
they've got this fleet of half a million
cars on the road
and they'll come up with a scenario that
the models not trained for the models
trained to deal with cars
it's trained to deal with bicycles but
what does it do when the car has
bicycles on it and you can dream up
these things all day so what they've
done is they have a second computer on
the car and they instruct the fleet of
cars to say if you see a picture that
looks like this send it back to us and
now they have targeted data to enhance
their models and very targeted in a
specific manner so it's not big data
it's the right pockets of data and I
think for that reason I think they're
gonna I wouldn't venture a guess of when
but I think they'll crack the code
sooner than many think
okay so last question and we're going to
wrap up
oh gosh that's not a short question yep
yep yep there isn't the LCM and I'll
tell you I'm not trying to duck you a
question I'll answer it in depth more
but long pole in the tent is generally
getting your data right and getting your
data clean and getting it to run through
as expected the architecture questions
are important but I'm going to save that
for after the lecture to talk about so
thank you guys I've been excited about
this and hand it back to Jeff
thank you very much as a few